In this video I want
to gain some experience in simplifying expressions,
as we have some more complex numbers included here.
These numbers are somewhat complex.
As always, try to pause this video
and see if you can simplify the phrase,
before I try.
Okay, I guess I tried it.
Now let's look at it.
We have minus 5.55 minus 8.55c plus 4.35c.
The first thing I want to do is see if I can unite
those articles involving c. I definitely can.
We can first get 8.55c with 4.35c
and it will be, to see,
it will be minus 8.55 plus 4.35,
I just collect the odds,
with and of course we still have
this minus 5.55 at the front.
Minus 5.55.
I'll just put a plus there.
But how can we calculate minus 8.55
plus 4.35?
There are several ways to look at it
or visualize it.
One way is to say that this is the same thing
with the negative of 8.55
minus 4.35,
to see now,
8 minus 4, this will be
negative, 8 minus 4 is 4,
55 hundred minus 35 cent
is 20 cent.
I can write 4.20,
which is the same as 4.2.
And all this can be replaced
minus 4.2.
The whole expression was simplified
to minus 5.55 and instead of saying plus minus 4.2s,
I can only write it as minus 4.2s
and we are ready.
This can not be simplified anymore.
We can not add this article, which it does not contain
the variable to that member that includes it.
This is as simple as possible.
Let's figure out another example.
Here I have even more complex numbers.
All of them are expressed as fractions.
Let's see, I have 2 / 5m minus 4/5, minus 3 / 5m.
How can I simplify?
I can put together all members containing m.
Let's just change the order.
I can write this again as 2 / 5m minus 3 / 5m,
minus 4/5.
I just changed the order.
We can see that I have these two members with m.
I can put them together.
This will be 2/5 minus 3/5
m and then I got minus 4/5
on the right.
How much is 2/5 minus 3/5?
This will be
minus 1/5.
I have minus 1 / 5m minus 4/5.
Minus 4/5.
So much.
I can not simplify it anymore.
I can not collect this article, which includes m, somehow
with this minus 4/5.
And here we are ready.
Let's decide more
one example.
Now, and that's interesting,
I have braces and then everything else.
As always, pause the video
and see if you can simplify this.
All right, let's solve it together.
The first thing I want to do,
is to allocate this pair so that
to have only three members that are
collected or subtracted.
If we uncover braces,
we will get 2 1 / 5m
is 2 / 5m.
Just make sure you see that m.
m is here.
2 minus 2/5 is minus 4/5
and then I have plus 3/5.
How can we simplify this?
I have these two members here,
which do not include the variable.
They are only numbers.
I can put them together.
I have minus 4/5 plus 3/5.
How much is minus 4 plus 3?
This will be minus 1.
So we will have a minus 1/5,
what is enclosed in yellow.
And I still have 2 / 5m,
2 / 5m minus 1/5.
And we're ready.
We have simplified this expression as much as we can.